[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLEN HARVEY: Everyone, welcome.
Welcome to Create App-like
Experiences on Google Search
and the Assistant.
I'm Allen Harvey.
I'm a product manager
on Google Search,
and I'm really excited
you all are here.
We're going to talk about
a new set of capabilities
that we're enabling
for you all to use
to create app-like
experiences on Google
Search and the Assistant.
These are new capabilities
not released before,
and we're really
excited that you're here
to learn about them.
So what am I going
to cover today?
Four things.
So I'm going to introduce
a new way to engage users
on Search and the Assistant.
I'm going to highlight these
unique, new capabilities
and talk about why they
can work for you all.
I'm going to show you how
to create one live onstage
and see it appear on Search.
And then I'm going explain
how you can get involved.
So as you all know,
Google's mission
and Google Search's mission
is to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
As a product manager
on Search, this
is what I work on every
day, figuring out new ways
that we can make Search
more useful to help
people find information
more quickly and easily.
And Search has started
out with blue links.
You're all familiar with them.
And they look something
like this on the left.
And over time, we've
added rich new formats
such as structured data and
content, carousels, larger
images, all working
to make Search
more useful for everybody
who comes and uses it.
And we've also added ways to
make Search more interactive.
So for example, if you
search for how many calories
are in an apple, you get a
simple interactive experience
like this.
It tells you the
answer right on Search
where you can choose,
say, the variety of all
of apples in the dropdown or the
amount in the second dropdown.
Now this is a simple
interactive component,
but it makes Search much
more valuable for people
who come looking for help.
Of course, if you keep looking,
say, how many meters are
in a yard, you'll
get an experience
that shows you the
conversion right
on Search, same simple drop
downs there, but a few more
of them, and also
different types of inputs
we're starting to introduce.
Here you can type answers,
type numbers and information
right into Search and see
the answer change right
on the search results page.
And of course, there's
the translation capability
we all know and love.
If you search for, say, how
do I say love in French,
you get the translation
right on Search.
And you can tap
in and change it.
You can see the translation
update in real time.
You can change which language
you translate between,
and you can expand
the experience
to see more details
about that translation.
All of this is starting to
introduce more interactivity
to the search results page.
And if you think about other
rich experiences we have,
such as weather or sports where
you see rich experiences that
are interactive,
helping users find
what they're looking for more
quickly and easily on Search.
And while we love
these experiences,
we know there's more to do.
You all have created some of
the most engaging and rich
experiences on the
internet whether you're
a web developer, an assistant
developer, or a native app
developer.
We said, how can we
expand upon this?
How can we help web
developers bring
rich, interactive, app-like
experiences to Search?
For example, you have
interactive actionable
workflows on your sites that
help users get things done,
to help you put the best
foot forward when somebody
comes to your site or service.
How could we help you
bring the beginning of that
to Search so you can engage
users right in the search
results page so they can start
that journey right on Search
or the Assistant?
Or if you're an
assistant developer,
and say you want
to create an action
that has a visual
aspect to it, how
can you build one that
works both on Search
and the Assistant?
How can we enable you to bring
those visual actions that
would work for both
services and build them?
And finally, if you're a native
app developer, many of you
may have static download pages
to engage users and tell them
why they should download
your application.
But how can we help you move
beyond a static download
page on the web and engage
users with a focused
subset of that functionality
right on search
or the Assistant so you start
to get a feel for your service
or product right away?
In short, we asked
ourselves, how can we
go from interactive
experiences created
by Google to rich, interactive,
app-like experiences
created by you all?
So today, I'm excited
to announce that we're
introducing Mini-apps.
So Mini-apps are a new
capability on Search
and the Assistant
that enable you all
to engage users with
interactive flows
and live content
right on each surface.
These capabilities
are new, and we're
going to give you an
early preview of this
and talk about how it'll work
and how you can get involved.
And we're excited to be
introducing this today.
All right, so why
build a Mini-app?
So Mini-apps appear right
on the search results page
among the blue links.
For example, standard, a set
of blue links on the left.
And if you're an online
course-providing company here,
you could create a Mini-app
that will appear right
among the blue links and
show a rich, interactive set
of results.
In this case, an
online course provider
might want to show its most
popular classes when somebody
searches for them to
make sure users see
all the rich content that
they offer right away
right on search.
They might want to
add interactivity
so a user can
discover what classes
are available by tapping in
to see which start this week
or those that are
made for beginners.
Mini-apps enable you to
bring your live content
and interactivity
right to Search.
But that's just the
first page of a Mini-app.
Mini-apps can do more.
They're designed
to make sure you
can build an experience
for users that
help you put your best
foot forward and engage
with the products
and services you
offer in unique ways on Search.
In this case, this
online course provider
has wanted to tell users about
the latest offerings they have
and let them discover more.
For example, in the
first page, they
would see those most
popular classes.
But a user could tap on
one, say, Google Cloud
certification, and see
more about the course.
But the user's journey
doesn't stop there.
Mini-apps enable you
to hand off the user
to the best place on your site
or service to engage them.
For example, if a user
decides they like this class,
they can tap More Info
to go to your site,
or if they wanted
to enroll right now,
they could tap
Enroll in This Course
and go to the right
place on your site
to begin enrolling immediately.
Of course, they can also
click View More Courses,
go back and see
the full carousel
of offerings that were appearing
right on the search results
page.
This new capability is
designed to enable you all
to engage users with the key
aspects of your offering right
on the surface.
But many of you may not
have real-time offerings
like this you want to show.
What if you need to help users
look up more information?
Mini-apps can also do that.
Say I'm a shipping
company and I want
to help users find the status
of a package right away.
This demo Mini-app--
this example Mini-app
we've created here,
on the left, you
see when I look for
to track a package
number with this
shipping company,
the Mini-app appears right
in the search results page
and prompts the user for input.
The user taps in, and you
get this expansive experience
that you see there
in the middle.
The user puts in their
package-tracking information,
clicks track, and sees the
real-time status of the package
appear right on search.
Now that real-time
information comes
because Mini-apps make a call
to your APIs and infrastructure
to get the real-time content.
So when you create a Mini-app,
the Mini-app calls in real time
your infrastructure to make
sure it's serving the content
that you know is the latest
that you want users to see.
But even in this case, the user
journey doesn't stop there.
It's decided by the company
that creates the Mini-app.
If you wanted to
enable users to call
you to get more
information, say there
is an exception in the
package-tracking journey
and the user needs to call
to understand what happened,
say, there's more functionality
and capability you
offer on your site.
The user could tap through
to, say, redirect a package
or view more information
about the package.
And finally, if they wanted
to track another one,
a user could click
Track Another Package,
go back to the middle
screen, and engage
right with your rich
experience right
on Search and the Assistant.
So Mini-apps, to help you
bring these rich capabilities
to Search and the
Assistant, we said
they had to do a
couple of things.
You saw them throughout
the examples.
First, they had to help you
all bring interactive workflows
to Search.
You all have built wonderful
services and capabilities.
And how can we help you help
users begin the journey right
on Search, starting with
interactive workflows that
take user input?
So as you saw, Mini-apps can
take user input and return
results right in line.
Second, our dynamic updates.
So Mini-apps, because
they're powered by webhooks,
they can show live content right
on Search and refresh results
as new information comes in.
And finally, of course,
there's on-surface fulfillment.
Mini-apps show right on Search
and right on the Assistant,
enabling you to put
your best foot forward
to show users the key aspects
of your product and service
right on Search
and the Assistant.
But that's not all.
We know you all have
built wonderful journeys.
We don't expect you
to have to recreate
the full journey on
the search results page
or on the Assistant.
If you take a look at that
first one we talked about,
the course exploration
Mini-app example, here the user
completed the initial steps
of that journey on Search.
They found the popular courses
that were interesting for them,
or they saw those
that were available,
those that were starting soon.
But then the Mini-app handed
the user off to your service
or app to continue and
complete the journey.
Now there may be cases where you
want to offer the most premium
experience you can and
make sure the user can
do everything right on
the search results page.
This case is the
shipping company
wanted to provide the complete
package-tracking information
right on Search.
Mini-app can do that, too.
So you can help users begin a
crucial piece of their journey
and get a single thing
done, such as discovering
the course they
like, or complete
the full journey such as finding
the status of their package.
They're designed to be able
to fit the needs of the users
you need to engage to help them
to get something done on Search
and get a good feel for
your services and products.
OK, so I've talked a
little bit about Mini-apps,
how we've designed them, the
key capabilities we have.
We've also built a few.
And we wanted to
demonstrate how they feel
and look because one of
the key aspects of them
is they're really fast and feel
really wonderful on Search.
So let me pull one up and
demonstrate it in front of you
right now.
So I've got a Pixel 3 here.
And I'm going to make
sure you can see it.
Great.
So this is a
demonstration Mini-app
that we've put together using
some of the live content
from Coursera.
It looks very similar to the
demonstration app I showed.
And it's appearing right here
in the search results page.
So in this case, I've looked
for Coursera machine learning.
You see the Mini-app there
appearing among the blue links
right on Search.
It's fully interactive.
You can swipe around and quickly
see more courses and offerings.
And I think this
Google Cloud, how
Google does machine learning
is pretty interesting.
I can tap in and I can
quickly get information.
You saw that actually
load in real time.
That was a webhook
call to actually get
the content to appear right
on the search results page.
This looks
interesting, but I want
to look around a
little bit more.
I can tap in if I want to
filter by TensorFlow because I'm
interested in machine learning
courses about TensorFlow.
Scroll through and
see what's available.
Serverless machine learning from
Google Cloud looks interesting.
Tap in, get that rich
exploration capability,
tap back to see more courses.
And even as a user, tap
out, and I'm right back
on the search results page.
Now keep in mind
how fluid and fast
this was, cutting
down on frustration
and churn for users,
enabling you to engage them
right on the surface with live
content and interactivity.
And once again,
if I wanted to, I
could tap through on More
Information or Enroll Now
to go directly to
your site or service.
Now of course, the
thing I promised
was that these worked on both
Search and the Assistant.
So I'm going to
switch over here.
And we've created a
demonstration Mini-app
on the Google Home Hub as well.
The goal of this is that
the Google Home Hub Mini-app
is powered by that
same live content that
powers the search one.
But we've laid out the
content a little bit
differently just to show how
it's suitable for the Home Hub
as well.
And Mini-apps can
help you do this
on both Search
and the Assistant.
I'll lean in because it's noisy.
And we'll see if the Home Hub
can show us Coursera's courses.
Hey, Google.
Show me machine learning
courses by Coursera.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Here is the list
of machine learning courses.
ALLEN HARVEY: So
you see the same set
of courses come up, powered
by the same webhook and APIs.
So this is a Mini-app
working on both Search
and working on the Assistant.
I can tap in to see
more information,
just like I could
on the Mini-app that
was appearing on Google Search.
You see the same
information here.
It's scrollable.
Same content appearing
across multiple surfaces.
I'll just swipe out
of that to close.
So in a nutshell,
that's Mini-apps.
They enable you to create these
rich interactive experiences,
show up right on the
search results page,
and engage users with your
unique content and offerings
so users know what
you can offer to them.
So let's dig into
how Mini-apps work.
I give you an understanding
of how to create one
and what you can do with them.
All right, so how
do Mini-apps work?
I'm going to use this one.
We're going to create a
Hello World Mini-app today.
I'm going to walk
you through it,
and I'll talk through
the pieces of it.
This Hello World Mini-app
is fairly simple.
It's got an image there.
It's got some text, an input
box, and an update button.
I wanted to show
off as simply as I
could the input, the real-time
interactivity right on Search
and the Assistant.
So on this one, you'd
type in your name.
In this case, type
in some input.
My name is Allen.
Click Update, and the
string will change.
So instead of hello
from Google I/O 2019,
you'll get hello, Allen,
welcome to Google I/O 2019.
So how do they work?
Mini-apps basically
have two pieces to them.
There's the app itself.
We talked about this.
There's the configuration
information.
There's the user
interface definition,
and I'll get into that a
little bit in a minute.
And then there's the
triggering setup.
So those are the
three main components
of a Mini-app you define.
And then you set
up a webhook that
has the content and business
logic for your Mini-app
so that when the
Mini-app appears,
it can call your webhook to
get the latest information
and to understand
what it should show
and how it should
show it to the user.
So a quick demonstration,
when Google Search comes up
and the Mini-app triggers,
it says, hey, Mini-app.
I need you to show
on Google Search.
The Mini-app says to the
webhook, send me your content.
Pretty quick and easy.
The Mini-app turns
around, in our case,
returns that nice I/O 2019
image, returns the string.
Mini-app puts it together in
the user interface definition
and shows it right on
Search or the Assistant.
Now where do you
go to create them?
So for Mini-apps, they're
created in the Actions console.
And why the Actions console?
The Actions console
has the ability
to help you make Mini-apps
that work across surface.
So coming up in the
early access program,
Mini-apps will work on
Search with quick follow ons
for smart displays on
Google Assistant as well
as smart display and Google
Assistant on other devices.
In addition, in the
Actions console,
there's basically four easy
steps you follow to create one.
We talked about this.
You create the
app configuration.
You define your user
interface for each surface.
You set up triggering.
And then of course, you specify
the location of your webhook.
All right, I'm going to
walk you through each step.
They're quick and
hopefully pretty simple.
App configuration--
and I'm going
to use this app, the one
we've been talking about,
the Hello World app, and walk
through a sample configuration
with it.
So in the Actions
console, you'd go in
and you'd define a quick app
configuration for your app.
You set up the name.
We'll call this one the
Google I/O Mini-app.
Description, Hello World
Mini-app for Google I/O.
Since I'm creating it,
the company is Google,
and the URL is Google.com.
And we'll say for now the
supported languages and regions
are EU and US just
for the simple example
here in this demo.
And finally, I put an
example webhook URL there
in the configuration.
But a lot of the
magic in Mini-apps
is from this library of
UI components we offer.
So I talked about how
do you get a Mini-app
to show on Search
and the Assistant?
We've got a complete set
of UI components you use.
And Mini-apps on each
surface need to be Search
and Assistant UI
and UX compatible.
So we've created
these Mini-apps so you
don't have to sit
there and build
all new components yourself.
So we offer a complete
library of components.
Here I've picked an example few.
We've got text components and
carousel components, chips,
buttons, and images.
We try to make it really easy
for you to define the user
interface of your Mini-app.
For example, here's
if you wanted
to create the Update button
for our Hello World Mini-app.
You simply say button,
put in the text,
put an on-event
handler in there.
And then you've
got a button that
meets Search specifications
and Assistant specifications
that will appear
right on each surface.
Pretty simple and
easy to say, hey, I
need an update button
in my Mini-app.
And when it calls the webhook,
set up some event handlers
so I know what the user did.
Of course, we don't want you
to have to redefine your user
interface every time.
You take these set of
components and you package them
into what we call a UI template.
In this case, I've taken the
same set of four components--
an image, a label, an
input box, and some text--
and we'll package them together
in what we would call our UI
template for Search.
This way I can
reuse this template.
I can use it, and
you saw earlier,
Mini-apps have
many pages in them.
I could reuse templates
in certain pages
all to make it so you don't
have to rebuild the same UI
time and time again.
You can package them
together and use them
across different surfaces.
And of course, the same
would apply for something
such as Assistant.
So you could take
those same components.
Those components know how
to work on each surface.
But since each surface has
different capabilities,
you could lay them out
in a different way.
Here you see my text image
are now again side by side.
The large text that I
specified is now even larger
because it knows what to
do right on the Assistant.
And some of the input boxes have
turned into suggestion chips,
because you can just
speak to the Assistant
instead of typing in.
So the goal here is we wanted
to make Mini-apps as simple
as possible to create and set
up to help you engage users
on each surface.
All right, so finally
is triggering.
Triggering is where you
get a bit of Google magic
with Mini-apps.
So here's a really
simple example.
I've wanted to say I want
this Mini-app to show up
on search when somebody
types hello, world
or hello, Google
I/O. You notice,
I don't have to specify
misspellings or typos.
A lot of that is taken care of
when you register your Mini-app
for certain query examples.
And it's neat things
that when Google detects
that your Mini-app should
show when these examples have
happened, we'll make sure
that the Mini-app gets
the right inputs from the
user and knows when to appear
on Search or the Assistant.
OK, so Mini-apps are brand new.
So I've walked
through what they are.
I've walked through how do you
create one and how they work.
I'm going to build an example
one right in front of you.
We've got a quick
developer quick start guide
that I'm going to walk
through and set up a Mini-app
and show you that we
can make one today.
So I want to walk
you through this.
This is very early DevX.
Mini-apps are brand new from
Google search and the Assistant
teams.
So let's get started.
I'm just going to quickly
switch over to my laptop.
All right, so I've pulled up
Mini-apps developer quick start
guide here.
What I have going on
is I've got welcome
to developer quick start.
This helps you get started.
And we've got a developer
console here for Mini-apps.
I've created one already with
this Hello World Demo backup.
But I'm going to come in and
use what we have showing here
to create one.
I've got this app
configuration here
that I'm going to
show everybody.
So this Mini-app, we
talked about it, right?
Hello I/O Mini-app, the
Hello World Mini-app.
The providers of my company
will change that to Google.
And it will change
that to example.com.
And right here you can see
the intents I've set up,
so the Hello World intents.
And I've specified the
location of a webhook.
So I'm just going to
take this really quickly.
And I'm going to put this
in our console over here.
And I'm going to
create a new Mini-app.
So I've got a
back-up one created,
but I wanted to
create a new one.
So I'm going to create one
right in front of us, set up
this app configuration.
So you see the app config
here, Google I/O Mini-app,
Hello World Mini-app.
I'm going to change
this to Google
since I'm creating this one.
And I'm just going to click
Save on this Mini-app.
Great, so it says
saved, quick and easy.
Come back here to
the special place,
demo Hello World Mini-app.
You saw that created.
Now the next thing I need to do
is define that user interface,
right?
So I said there is this
set of components you
can use to create a Mini-app.
So I want to define this user
interface really quickly.
I'm going to come back here
to my developer quick start.
So in the user interface,
what did I say I need?
I said I needed some
components, right?
The first one was
this image piece here.
So I wanted to show
off this image.
The second one was
a text block that I
wanted to show off and put
in a quick line in there.
Then an input button
for the input your name,
and then a button
to take the update.
So I'm going to pull
and take this here.
And I'm going to
come on over here,
my developer console and define
my user interface template.
So this is pretty simple
on the Mini-app, right?
I've got my image.
And that image,
you notice, says it
comes from payload.image URL.
This mean your webhook
returning that live content puts
that image right
in the Mini-app.
I've got the text block.
For the Mini-app we wanted to
show the message Hello, World
or Hello from Google I/O showing
right on the search results
page.
So I've got payload
and output message.
That means pull from the webhook
call, that output message,
and show it in the Mini-app.
And then we wanted
that input button.
And remember, for our
app configuration here,
we're triggering on--
this webhook I'm
calling in Hello World.
So I'm going to quickly
go over and test this.
And run one more time.
I'm going to come back here
and make sure that I configured
everything OK.
Click Save.
Hello, World-- looks
like my-- there it goes.
Sorry, a few hiccups
reaching my webhook
endpoint that I just set up.
So I've got my Hello World
Mini-app working right there.
Here's the user
interface I defined.
Here's the image.
Here's the texturing.
I can type in right
here on Search.
Update that Hello, Allen.
You saw that work right here
live on the search results
page.
You can see the
request we send out.
So we talked about this, right?
So it sends out-- here's
the input from that button,
and the string value is Allen.
And then you can see
the response that
comes back from the webhook.
Hey, the payload,
which we talked about,
had that image URL in it and it
had the output message showing.
So you saw that work
right there on Search.
And I've created a Mini-app.
Now we've also gone and said
so I've got this Cloud function
webhook that's set up.
And I'll go into
this in a second.
But what I've seen is you
see this Mini-app working.
So we've also created one
that works on the Assistant.
And so I wanted to show
that this webhook powers
both the Assistant and Search.
So let me invoke the Mini-app
on the Assistant really quickly.
Hey, Google.
Show me the Hello World Demo.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hello
from Google I/O 2019.
What's your name?
ALLEN HARVEY: My name is Allen.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hello, Allen.
Welcome to Google I/O 2019.
ALLEN HARVEY: So there you
saw the same application
working right on Search
and the Assistant.
Give me two seconds here.
I'm going to switch
back to my laptop.
And one of the
things I wanted to do
is when I created this
Mini-app, I used this image.
So I used this image
to create my Mini-app.
But there's also this other
great Google I/O image.
And to show you how it
updates in real time,
I'm going to swap over
to this image here.
So I'm going to go over here.
I've built this
Cloud function here
to help us get started easily.
It's just a simple JSON
takes a request and response.
And this is what is the
response is coming back
for the Mini-app.
And I'm going to swap
over to this new image.
It's a really quick
simple update.
Here's the image URL.
You saw here is the
payload I specified earlier
and returning that image URL.
Pretty quick and
simple to update.
Now I'm going to deploy this.
This takes a moment to deploy.
So we'll let that deploy.
But one of the things I
wanted to talk through
while that's deploying
is what's exciting
about Mini-apps is you can
also get a quick preview of how
they'll look on Google Search.
So we see this View in Google
Search button down here.
I'm going to click this
just while this happens.
And you see, hey, look,
showing right there
in the Google
Search results page
I can get a nice
preview of my new app,
get a feel for how it'll
show right there on Search.
And this is private to you.
Only you can see
that, but you can
get a sense of how the
Mini-app is working right
on Google Search.
So I'm going to back here.
You see this Mini-app working.
I'm going to check in
on my Cloud Function.
Still deploying.
It takes a second here.
And come back-- and so
there it is, the preview.
And you could put
anything in here.
It's just to show that it
can take some live content.
Right here on Search,
we'll update that, Hello,
everyone, showing that the
Mini-app can take that input.
Now my web function is deployed.
I'm going to rerun
my Mini-app here.
And now you saw the
image change because I
deployed that new Cloud
Function with the new image.
So we've got the same APIs
powering your Mini-app
right on search, showing
that they are powered
by the same webhook
calls that you
saw me modify in that webhook.
And now I'm going to switch
back to the Assistant
because that Assistant
Mini-app is also
using that same webhook.
And in the Assistant, you'll see
that the second image updates
because that's where it
expects the payload response.
So let's see if this
works right for us.
Hey, Google, show me
the Hello World Demo.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hello
from Google I/O 2019.
What's your name?
ALLEN HARVEY: My name is Allen.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hello, Allen.
Welcome to Google I/O 2019.
ALLEN HARVEY: So you see
the image change there?
I updated in the webhook.
You see the same
webhook response.
You setup once, powering your
application both on Search
and on Home Hub, making it
simple to build a Mini-app that
works across surface.
All right, let's go
back to the slides.
So Mini-apps-- they
enable developers
to engage users with
interactive workflows
and live content directly
on Search and Assistant.
And this is a brand new
early adopters program
that we're talking about today.
This is brand new
from us on Search
and the Assistant,
brand new ways
to engage users with interactive
experiences and live content.
Remember they've got
three key capabilities
we wanted to introduce.
They can take and respond
to user input right and line
on Search.
They can show live content as
new updates become available,
and they enable you to engage
users directly on each surface.
And finally, of course,
they have flexible handoff
so that you can direct the
user to the right place
in your service so
that they have the best
experience on their journey.
So if you have a
use case or you can
help a user accomplish a task
or retrieve more information
in a more delightful way
using these capabilities,
we want to hear from you.
We want to hear what you
can do with Mini-apps.
We built these to enable
you all to engage users
on each surface using these
unique new capabilities.
So today, I'm
excited to announce
that we're opening up an early
adopters program for Mini-apps.
The submissions are open now.
And the invitations
are coming in June
for those first submissions.
Please go to g.co/miniapps
to get started.
As I mentioned, we're really
excited to see what do you all
want to build with Mini-apps?
How can you all
engage users on Search
and the Assistant
with Mini-apps?
So thank you so
much for your time.
I'm Allen Harvey, and please
visit g.co/miniapps to get
started.
And tell me what you would
like to create with them today.
Thanks a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]